hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign we got some
interesting news to talk about today a
centurion and gladiator rework beta test
as well as possibly new armor coming
within this season or next season
as there's a hell of a lot of other
things like twitch drops so as always
like
if you do enjoy guys subscribe if you're
new i covered the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
here updates the patchworks and the
leaks
if you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
warner and never miss out on an update
definitely subscribe to the channel and
with that let's get started
so yeah quick recap jorman gander is
releasing today if you have the year
three season pass you can hop
in game now and play yorman gander right
now on august 1st or if you don't have
the year three season pass don't worry
you can get access to your man gander
next week on august 8th but you do have
to pay 15 000 steel to buy the hero
on top of that the pc standard edition
is also free on the epic game store from
august 2nd to august 9th it's only going
to be available for that week but once
you get it you can keep it so honestly
if you're probably never going to play
it or maybe play it one or two times
just get it right now and then maybe
come back to it every once in a while
because
i'd rather have that than just you know
be that one time that you hop on and
your friends maybe want to play on pc
but you forgot to download it during the
week next up is the thing called twitch
drops every season they usually do this
i've never really taken part in it since
i've never really streamed on twitch but
now since i've been streaming on twitch
recently
and by the way link in the description
for that we're going to be streaming on
twitch all week with these twitch drops
every single
streamer is going to have the
availability to give twitch drops to the
viewers
basically on screen right now you're
seeing a graphic of what it looks like
if you watch about an hour of a stream i
believe that's the minimum then you get
an xp boost and go all the way up to 24
hours which is the highest
and just to help you guys out those of
course are going to be the in-game
rewards that you will be getting so i'm
going to be streaming every single day
for that entire week
from august 1st to august 7th so i'll be
streaming every single day and as soon
as this video goes live i'll most likely
be streaming on twitch
so make sure to subscribe and turn on
the notifications you guys can get the
updates on the community post and also
join my discord so when you can get
information some of you guys can join my
stream since i'm going to be streaming
on twitch
because i want to help you guys out get
those awards and it's okay if you don't
if you're not really going to pay
attention to the stream i totally get it
if you want to play some xbox you want
to play some playstation you'll grind
out while i'm
on sitting on your desktop that's
completely understandable as long as
you're within the stream
and it's up on your desktop you will be
getting those rewards regardless so
definitely hop into the stream this
whole week
i'm going every single day for this
whole week so definitely come by if you
guys want to get some in-game rewards
so next up we have is the roadmap they
showed this to us immediately which is
good news
we're going to be getting the usual
arcade quests and challenges as well
there's going to be a double xp on the
16th
carousel of death is going to be on the
22nd and on 29th is going to be the
testing grounds if you did not watch my
video from last week the testing grounds
was this old little beta test that's
going to be happening
uh like before seasons and seasons ago
what we used to have was that
there would be like the small little
test of small little changes mostly pc
players could play it the console
players i believe only got one time to
do it
but now every single person is going to
be able to play this console pc
uh eu n a doesn't matter everyone's
going to be able to play this and in
that is going to be
the season 11 reworks like we talked
about which is going to be centurion
gladiator warlord those are going to be
in the testing ground so definitely hop
in and play that stuff
i'm going to be streaming my reaction as
well on that day so definitely stay
tuned for the 29th
and i'll let you guys know how i think
about the gladiator rework i'm going to
be playing a lot of videos with that
because you know gladiator is my boy
on top of that we also got some new
content of the week and that's going to
be emotes these are faction specific
we have mate virtue for the knights agai
tavel for the vikings asaba rashi
for the samurai and zhud hao for the
wulin i believe is that the name
and for more content there's going to be
an event playlist on the faction map
which is a 24 7 playlist for store
stronghold
which is the new breach map for season
11 so if you like breach and you like
the new map
which we talked about last week you're
going to be super excited for this i'm
going to be playing this a lot on stream
today so i'm super excited because
you're not big fan of breech
also a really cool looking map next up
they did a q a and for a quick recap we
got a lot of nice news to talk about
they planned on making more moves like a
roach's newest move
like we said uh like we talked about
last week orochi is gonna be one of the
bigger characters that's going to be
getting a change this
season one of them is that i believe one
of his attacks i think it's the heavy
attack so the light attacks are now
going to be 466 milliseconds as opposed
to 500 milliseconds
so they're going to be doing small
increments of 33 millisecond
divisions instead of just having 100
milliseconds so they're going to be
testing that and if it goes well they're
going to be adding more stuff to other
characters that have increments of moves
like this so
who knows raiders stunning type could be
even quicker i'm just totally joking of
course but
instead of having 500 ms 600 ms 400 it's
going to be a lot more smaller numbers
like 466
433 uh 366 or 560 you know stuff like
that so it's going to be really cool
it's going to be getting
right down to the perfect amount of
speed that we want for those moves so
i'm really hyped for that
i know this was talked about last week
by a lot of other youtubers as well i
just didn't really get to cover it
but regarding the centurion gladiator
and the warlord changes slash reworks
centurion will have the biggest change
it is confirmed by the developers he
will have the biggest change of the
reworks
gladiators going to be getting a
medium-sized change and warlord's going
to have a slight change for this as well
but centurion means you guys are going
to be getting the biggest bunch
gladiator mains like myself we're going
to be getting some nice changes well
hopefully the guard
is also buffed up i've been waiting
three seasons for that and remember the
test build for those lyrics is going to
be on august 29th
and anyone can play it and it doesn't
matter what platform or region you're on
and it's really to give devs feedback so
when the reworks end up do releasing the
next season
they aren't completely broken and
they're exactly what we want it to be
as for new armor they mentioned that
they will be releasing some soon in
quotation marks along with weapons my
guess is this is either next season or
during the event in the middle of the
season for yormin gander
back in season 8 the old roster got a
lot of new armor as well and it was also
hinted that the dlc characters from year
one
that being shaman aramus highlander
shinobi centurion and gladiator
will most likely be getting a whole new
armor this time if there is going to be
armor next season or in the middle of
the current season
and not just variations like we did back
in season eight and the armor for the
minions during the events will look a
lot more historically traditional
as opposed to the other stuff that we've
been getting like the rabid stuff that
was really cool though as we get more
into the future with the more events and
the more seasons
we will be getting a lot more
historically traditional looks on their
characters
and then lastly they're still really
trying to help pk so any peacekeeper
players the five of you that are still
out there i believe in you guys
but they're they're taking very small
baby steps to get into this
like they did with the season 11 patch
she actually has some changes coming in
the season 11 patch they're very small
but they're taking small baby steps
because they don't want to overshoot it
and make her super deadly
like they used to have her she had like
40 damage on her deep gouge which was a
disgusting move and that was why she was
so powerful
so then they nerfed her and then she
became way too less powerful
and now she's at like the bottom of the
list so hopefully she'll get a good spot
eventually so we'll have to see
what those other small steps are going
to be in the near future okay guys it's
going to be the end of the video hope
you guys did enjoy it like i said
throughout this entire week i'm going to
be streaming the new season if you guys
just want to play xbox play playstation
you know do whatever you want while i'm
in the background totally understand
that as long as you're on the stream
you're going to be getting those in-game
rewards i'm not sure when this ends in
terms
i'm not sure in terms of when you're
going to be getting these rewards but i
do know that you have to watch at least
24 hours
uh to get the maximum number which is
the 24 hours before
august 7th so definitely come into my
stream i'm going gonna try to be
streaming at least 24 hours within that
week
so for the people that only watch me you
guys can get those awards as well and
even when i'm not on stream you guys can
also watch other people those count as
well
so like i said that'll be live in about
30 minutes or so roughly as soon as this
video goes up and the patch is up and
the servers are back up because they're
doing a maintenance right now so yeah
definitely come by in the stream check
the community post check the discord
join all that stuff we want to be kept
up to date because i know those twitch
drops are going to be cool
because i mean you're just getting
rewards for doing literally nothing i
mean why wouldn't you take this
okay guys as always like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new i cover
the informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patriots and the leaks
if you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
for honor and never miss out on an
update
definitely stay subscribed to the
channel and then guys hope you have a
great yesterday thank you for watching
the video enjoy season 11 hopefully i'll
see you in my stream this week
and peace out guys have a great
yesterday
you